[Music]
cause he was talking [ __ ] when he came
on our podcast yeah [ __ ] did you see
that oh bro [ __ ] jake
he's the dumbest [ __ ] like he
is
let's
so like after
me being logan yeah i
stopped doing the whole boxing thing for
like two three years to focus on music
to you know work on the foundations
improve my music blah blah blah you know
i've actually recently released a music
video maybe that's another thing that's
get the [ __ ] out of him i did a music
video where i'm like boxing and training
uh alex's time and alex probably saw
that i was just like nah [ __ ] this bro
but anyway um i leave to do music and
jakes you know fine all these random
people and some nba um
player and then um
[Laughter]
but he's not being smart he's not create
he's not like with me with misfits i'm
trying to be an eddie hearn i'm trying
to build everyone up build a whole fight
card build
other fighters build everyone up so that
there's this like huge league with
everyone and then it's just like okay
there's constant fight and i don't need
to fight every time and it's still me
building up this misfits brand yeah
with jake it's all me me me me mimi i i
gotta i gotta say amanda serrano he's
done great okay okay yeah but because
nobody cared about female
is true but who else who else katie
taylor was the other girl that she
fought at the garden yeah but that was
an amazing that's not related that was
incredible yeah that's not related i
think i think she's with eddie yeah but
yeah yeah but like he's trying to do
like fighter pay and all that stuff like
he's trying to yeah i know he's trying
to understand what you're saying like
you're almost trying to like ufc of five
boxes which is like if you have the
great thing about ufc is like all the
fighters are under the same promotion
so that like
it behooves you to have entertaining
fights not fighters who've never lost
right with boxing you promote the a side
the b side you get some tomato can from
down the block to come lose the people
don't see an engaging fight that's it no
one's just that's i'm trying to
improve everyone that's smart everyone
wins and then it's like you can build
everyone blah blah blah blah it creates
fights and it's not like so for example
let's say alex doesn't fight or why he's
not fighting and i can just replace him
and people are still interested in the
other fights they're still my brother
fighting fousey they're still temper
versing another opponent there's still
you know all these other fights that
people like i'm still intrigued with the
whole card whereas with the jake fight
yeah you just jake versus um
rachman is it yeah yeah yeah and then
serrano versus whoever she was fired
yeah that's it it's like yeah yeah
that's that is another thing with ufc's
where you know like six of the fights on
the card when you're watching you've got
to build the whole card and jake just
didn't hasn't been doing that especially
if you're charging 70 bucks now
like
60 dollars yeah yeah don't mind
the [ __ ] scene that's [ __ ] more
than utic versus
aj yeah yeah are you stupid yeah why bro
i couldn't believe it i was like why not
be smart charge less so more people want
to watch it or invested in it and make
you that's how you grow a brand that's
how you grow everything yeah it's not
about let me scan my [ __ ] yeah my
audience as fast as possible and bro he
what also he doesn't do yeah he's [ __ ]
off youtube the place that made him what
he was you gotta keep pumping content
down i'm still i'm still on youtube
making videos yeah i never forget where
i've come from and i'm still there just
pumping pumping and i'm still doing
music i'm still doing um boxing i'm
still doing other entities you know
cyber etc but i'm still on my youtube
channel posting videos because i know
that's where my core audience is and
that is like the heart that's my heart
and if that stops pumping everything
else slowly dies
and jade just he's always denouncing
that he's a youtuber and i'm like why
how did the beef get this bad though
cause this all seems like different
opinion different strategy and then this
you got legit like i don't like this
much i've never [ __ ] liked him i
think he's a [ __ ] [ __ ] bro no no
i like jake man that's a sweet kid
you're talking
about when you were hearing them hit me
up with like oh but he did do this and
do this i was like okay you you i knew i
i admired what he did like yeah but his
history though is not great why what
happened just with him saying the like
the n-word a few times behind closed
doors wait he said the n-word yeah yeah
bro like are you just saying this no go
if you can't argue
[Music]
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
but uh yeah no but and he thinks he's
better
he thinks he's [ __ ] better than me
man i love this he thinks he thinks he's
the top dog he thinks he's the a side
i'm like [ __ ] you don't know [ __ ] man
and duke it out right yeah when are you
gonna [ __ ] him up well that's why it's
nice
like you [ __ ] up one brother [ __ ] up
the other one so
so for me like my there's a there's a
strategy to this okay
i'm thinking all right first fight i
want to just get rid of the cobwebs show
everyone how [ __ ] sick i am okay and
that's what wasabi was that's what
wasabi was me to just dance around him
and just slap him sleep other people
know him i'm sorry to like interrupt i
mean no no no it was god i don't know if
that's his real name or if you're doing
a joke no his his name his internet name
alex wasabi he has fans
apparently i'm i'm sure i don't know
what does he do is he honestly or
something like that
i think he's just the social media guy
okay and he i don't know
it's just but like when you're when
you're deciding to have the fight this
is an odd decision oh no i couldn't give
a [ __ ] about him like because he's just
he's just there like
where
do you know the name like
for real
i mean i might not know i truly didn't
know the name i'm gonna put in wasabi in
on google right now no i guarantee my
dog comes up
100
i'm just so confused food